autorise effectivement à rentrer en
france ou non avec l'enfant et la
deuxième audience qui se passe donc une
heure après ce sera sur la pension
alimentaire
en europe la moitié des 350 milles
mariages binationaux se termine en
divorce
la france et l'allemagne sont les états
membres qui compte la plus grande
proportion de divorce binationaux est ce
qu'il est possible que le juge disent ok
et de voir madame la nhtsa lagarde et
loire mais pour le bien être de l'enfant
nous décidons quelques elle reste dans
la région de munich non non c'est pas
nous c'est le problème c'est que j'ai
une relation franco-allemande qui est un
peu plus difficile plus ça va dans ce
sens des divorces et plus je m'aperçois
que là on n'a absolument rien en commun
entre l'allemagne et la france
il ya des lois différentes mentalités
différentes des divorces rendu encore
plus difficile par le jugendamt
l'équivalent de la dass en france cette
autorité enquête et influencent la
décision du juge sur la garde de
l'enfant
bien souvent son avis favorise le parent
allemand du côté des autorités
françaises sandra se sentent assez peu
soutenu elles ont d'ailleurs refusé de
répondre à nos questions j'ai vraiment
très déçu par le comportement de
certaines autorités françaises au nom de
cette sacro-sainte un réunion
franco-allemande
justement je pense que tout défendre
faire respecter les libertés de chacun
c'est ça qui fait une union plus forte
jusqu'à présent dans les divorces
binationaux il y avait un flou juridique
c'était la course à celui qui allait
enclencher le premier la procédure dans
le pays dont la juridiction ne semblait
la plus favorable
désormais quatorze pays de l'union
européenne ont choisi de faciliter ces
divorces reste les associations pour les
parents en détresse à paris sos papa
apporte une aide juridique et
psychologique au père en instance de
divorce non gardé garder garder courage
il ya des outils techniques il ya des
outils juridiques à utiliser nous sommes
là pour vous aider monsieur face au
parcours du combattant que représente un
divorce binational l'union européenne va
faciliter les procédures dès juin 2012
un couple binational qui souhaitera
divorcé pourra choisir la loi qui
s'applique
une nouveauté qui devrait simplifier les
démarches de ses parents en instance de
divorce il ya 170 mille couples
binationaux qui divorce dans la seule
europe actuellement
il est évident que c'est un progrès
significatif dans le droit qui a un
petit peu des couples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes et va avoir un outil pour
disposer d'eux mêmes mais les enfants
sont laissés pour compte des enfants
prise en otage et pour qui cet accord
européen n'a rien réglé
si joëlle garriaud-maylam sénatrice
représentant les français de l'étranger
reconnaît le progrès que représente
cette mesure elle regrette l'absence
d'accord sur le droit de garde des
enfants
il ce qui manque surtout c'est le
règlement des dispositions en matière de
droits de garde des enfants
là nous avons des problèmes
considérables en matière de garde en
matière de structure de l'aide apportée
aux enfants et nous nous rendons compte
que malheureusement certains états
privilégient davantage leurs
ressortissants que peut-être l'intérêt
supérieur du droit de l'enfant
car le bien-être de l'enfant est souvent
le grand oublié dans les divorces
binationaux des enfants qui sont parfois
malgré eux privé d'une partie de leur
identité
voilà un reportage de flora sauvages
alors l'europe se préoccupe désormais de
ce problème des divorces entre les
couples binationaux on en parle avec
vous françoise castex eurodéputée
socialiste et rapporteur au parlement
européen sur cette question vous qui
avez travaillé sur ce problème
un divorce c'est déjà pas facile quand
en plus il ya des soucis de deux
frontières ça devient carrément un
casse-tête vous qui est vous êtes penché
sur cette question est ce que
aujourd'hui l'union européenne est en
mesure d'apporter une réponse à ces
couples alors l'union européenne apporte
une partie de réponse
je crois qu'il est extrêmement
symbolique que la première coopération
renforcée c'est à dire une coopération
quelques états membres qui décident à 14
là en l'occurrence et non pas à 27 de
collaborer pour quelque chose
il est symbolique ça touche les divorces
binationaux puisque ça concerne quand
même 140 milles
du divorce dans l'union européenne dit
coopération renforcée explique ont juste
que c'est ça veut dire que ce n'est pas
tout les pays qui seront concernés par
tout les saillies qui sont concernés par
le règlement qui a été votée en décembre
ce sont quatorze pays
quatorze états membres qui ont décidé
d'aller un peu plus vite que les autres
alors comment justement alors un menteur
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont mis en commun ils
n'ont pas harmoniser les règles du
divorce dans chacun de leurs états
membres dans le reportage on voit que la
dame découvre qu'il y a des trucs très
grande différence entre la loi allemande
la loi française la coopération
renforcée va maintenir toutes ces
différences simplement ce qu'elle change
c'est qu'elle arrive à trancher quel va
être le choix de la loi applicable
la seule chose que règle cette
coopération renforcée c'est d'éviter
qu'ils aient des conflits des conflits
de lois c'est à dire très concrètement
un couples qui souhaitent divorcer est
l'un des deux parce qu'il connaît les
différences juridiques va très vite
déposé la demande de divorce dans l'état
membre qui lui est le plus favorable qui
défendra le plus favorablement ça voilà
ça veut dire ça va se faire d'un autre
côté au détriment du doigt la conjointe
donc souvent celui qui
dépose le premier est en position de
force et on s'est aperçu que cette
course au tribunal et se faisait
toujours aux dépens du plus faible
alors désormais la relève sera mieux
protégé alors le plus faible sera plus
mieux protégés dans la mesure où la
procédure pour savoir quelle loi va
s'appliquer ce règlement définit un
ordre de priorité la première priorité
c'est le choix de façon conjointe des
époux pour la loi applicable qui est
soit celle du pays où ils résident soit
5 ans a complètement moment où il dépend
où il dépose la demande de divorce
c'est là où ils disent moi je souhaite
moi la tombe des folles ce soir là qui
s'applique voilà il dépose dans l'état
qui va prononcer le divorce 1 mais cette
ce règlement n'oblige pas un état à
reconnaître quelque chose qui ne
reconnaît pas par exemple malte est qui
et qui participe à cette coopération
renforcée ce qui est un peu paradoxale
puisque mal coordonnés grâce à
l'ajustement moi je suis française je
vais épouser un grec
une décision nous installé à ammal
qu'est ce qui se passe pour l'acheter
vous ne pourrez pas divorcer a mal donc
on est obligé de partir si on veut pas
voilà c'est à dire que la coopération
renforcée ce appliquera pour vous pour
choisir l'une des deux uhry diction qui
vous concerne mais ça on ne peut pas on
ne pourra pas obligé maltais a prononcé
un divorce ça reste la législation
nationale alors pour comme on parle de
cette question il ya aussi un autre
problème qui se pose qui est posée par
l'un des interlocuteurs de notre
reportage écoutez elle s'adresse à vous
vous allez lui répondre après
comme vous le savez l'europe fonctionne
à vitesse réduite sur le droit des
enfants à leurs deux parents de manière
égale après séparation du couple
parental
certains pays en août une résidence
alternée d'autres fonctionnent encore
avec des droits de visite et
d'hébergement
ma question sera à quand la mise en
oeuvre d'une véritable résidence en
alternance européenne permettant aux
enfants de voir leur papa et leur maman
de manière équitable
alors est-ce qu'on peut envisager ça ce
sera sans doute dans une prochaine étape
puisque ce règlement
sur la coopération renforcée ne couvre
pas la responsabilité parentale
elle ne couvre pas le responsable des
parallèles ne couvre pas les conflits en
temps sur les pensions alimentaires
voilà l or c'est paradoxal parce que
c'est quand même une question très
importante c'est vrai devrait
logiquement faire mais c'est un premier
pas et d'ailleurs nous avons voté en
même temps que ce règlement une clause
de rendez vous dans cinq ans pour
évaluer la portée et l'application de
cette coopération renforcée
éventuellement aller plus loin à les
plus grands par exemple on l'élargissant
aux civils ou aux couples homosexuels
voilà actuellement ils ne font pas
partie de ne sont pas concernés ils ne
sont pas concernés c'est à dire non
seulement ils ne sont pas cons c'est un
état membre ne peut pas prononcer en
divorce pour un mariage des homosexuels
si lui même ne le reconnais pas dans sa
loi c'est encore les législations
nationales totalement différent la
veille allait de même que cette ce
règlement s'applique à la séparation de
corps mais par contre ne peut pas
dissoudre en taxes vous voyez il y a
donc encore extrêmement de restrictions
et de limitation à cette coopération et
de même que en matière de de pension
alimentaire 22 de responsabilité civile
de partage patrimoniale de
responsabilité parentale c'est au delà
du champ d'application comprends bien
vous dites il ya déjà un premier pas
vous avez participé à la mise en place
de cette coopération renforcée dans le
domaine du divorce on voudrait savoir
concrètement est ce que un couple qui
qui qui souhaitent s'appuyer sur
l'europe quand t'as qu'à partir de quels
horizons il peut compter sur une
législation existante ratification
rapide à partir du moment où maintenant
elle est
elle est votée cette cette législation
s'applique il faut qu'elles paraissent
au journal officiel je sais pas si elle
est parfois ça peut être long le temps
entre une église et il n'y aura pas de
transposition c'est un règlement
il s'applique directement qui s'applique
directement il n'y a pas de procédure de
transposition dans les états membres ce
n'est pas une directive dans un
appartement où c'est publié au journal
officiel
je n'ai pas vérifié ça l'était déjà ça
s'appelait et africable et bien on a
bien compris merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous pour parler de cette question
importante et les citoyens européens à
françoise castex se demande souvent
quels sont leurs droits
on essaie de leur répondre dans cette
émission chaque semaine l'europe est au
bout du fil
question aujourd'hui de benjamin mon vol
de paris vers la martinique a été
annulée au dernier moment quels sont mes
droits
écoutez la réponse bonjour benjamin en
cas d'annulation de vol la législation
européenne nous protège en fait la
compagnie aérienne doit vous proposer
soit le remboursement de vos tickets
soit le réacheminement vers votre
destination finale c'est à vous de
choisir
en outre la compagnie aérienne doit vous
donner la possibilité de vous héberger
si nécessaire ainsi que la possibilité
de vous restaurer en plus de tout cela
vous aurez le droit d'une indemnisation
sauf en cas de circonstances
extraordinaire compte par exemple une
grève d'un tribut
voilà et vous pouvez vous aussi posez
votre question europe direct notre
partenaire vous réponds numéro facile à
retenir
0 800 6 7 8 9 10 11 voilà pour cette
émission présentée depuis strasbourg
avec nora ahmadi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine très bottines de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires